you're an Enthusiast for cycling as you
say in the piece but you really don't
like ebike yes they're a fraud they look
they look like bikes they make people
think that they're riding bikes and they
they also are allowed into the cycle
Lanes which it took Decades of
campaigning to get in which is supposed
to be free of Motor Vehicles and they
are Motor Vehicles they're bike-shaped
objects but they're actually motorbikes
and many of them can go extremely fast
and many of them are very heavy indeed
and so the whole battle which I took
part in which took past 40 years to get
special spaces on the roads for
human-powered lightweight silent clean
bicycles has now been tossed to one side
so these horrible themes can go whizzing
and whining along bike tracks and
excessive speeds and we aren't safe
anymore